almost all the letters that get sent in
the united states are processed
automatically you put a letter in a post
box it's taken to the closest processing
center where cameras and computers take
a picture of the front of the envelope
read the address with optical character
recognition ocr and it's then passed on
to the right truck or plane that deals
with pretty much everything even the
handwritten letters
but what if your handwriting is really
bad like really bad or the envelope got
a bit damp and the ink blurred and ran
the postal service sends the picture of
the envelope here to the remote encoding
center the wreck in salt lake city utah
and it's the job of the folks here to
turn scroll and blurred ink into actual
addresses it's a quiet day here today
mail volumes are low in the middle of
summer so while it's not busy inside
i'm going to see if i'd be any good at
this we're in the
last remote coding center in the united
states back in 1997 when we had 55 recs
open all of those wrecks combined keyed
19 billion images
the ocr technology is so good that in
2021 as the last wreck remaining we only
keyed 1.2 billion images right now we
have about 810 employees here shortly
we're going to be teaching tom how to
process some of this mail it'll be a lot
of fun
it's important to say that i can't show
you any actual mail not the envelopes
not anything if any appears in the
background on a screen it'll be blurred
out that's all considered strictly
private and besides i'm not gonna flash
random people's addresses on the screen
of a youtube video particularly when
they'll usually be written in
distinctive handwriting you can probably
work out how that could go wrong but
there is a stack of demonstration mail
envelopes and dresses used for training
and that's what i'm going to be tested
on if you drop off a piece of mail it
makes it to the local processing plant
if the machine can't read your
handwriting one of the keyers here will
type in the missing information and the
information goes right back to the plant
stays within automation which is a whole
lot cheaper than having somebody
physically
sort that piece by hand all right
what do i need to do i'll be putting
your last name and first initial into
that yeah i looked at the keyboard to
look for the numbers and realized that
this is a that is not a standard
keyboard that is not a standard keyboard
other than the quality letters and the
the numpad everything is different okay
to make everything faster for us they
did some weird things with the keyboards
that they've provided us the home row
asdf those also work
as your numbers you can't reach up to
the top of the keyboard to hit
one two three how to key the outward
portion of a male piece image we're
calling outward the city and the state
city and the state okay siemens came up
with this in the 90s
so they decided c coding is going to
mean zip code outward is going to mean
city and state okay inward is going to
mean the street address and that's now
the language that you use because that's
what they decided to make it faster to
key these letters our keying is a small
extract of what's on the letter and then
it compares it to the known good
addresses in the database every known
good address in america is sitting on
our servers in the back if it's good the
piece just goes away and you're done
if it matches a couple of good addresses
then you'll get a list and you'll choose
out of that list which is the address
you're trying for it makes it a whole
lot faster than typing out the entire
thing key in the first three characters
of the first word in the city name okay
first character of the second word two
character state or territory
abbreviation
it's the three plus one rule it's the
same for the street addresses okay press
the go key when ready go
so that is
l-e-t-m-s
oh three plus one rule if there's not
three characters you got to do a space
ah okay i gotta clear it out with the
enter key so that is l e space t m s
c s key cs oh city state got it okay
some pieces are buffered and some pieces
are live that live mail will be sitting
on a conveyor belt going around the
machine those flats and those packages
if we don't key them in 90 seconds and
get the information back to that machine
it dumps it off into a reject bin and
somebody has to hand sort that so for
the letters they run them through the
machine one time they store them off to
the side a few hours later they put them
in the machine the second time
anticipating that we've processed
everything that was missing oh
i'm guessing that's like dixon hill or
something like that i can't tell that's
dic or dx ox hill and i see it as a tail
yes
okay
okay
oh remember these are the easiest ones
to read the test so i really can't get
ready every year we
have fewer and fewer pieces we've got
fewer people handwriting mail
and we have ocr technology that's really
good i'll bet we went from somewhere in
the neighborhood of less than half of
the mail being read by a computer in the
90s to
nearly 99 of letters being read today
the ocrs that are reading the letter
mill i think it's close to 99 percent
yeah so we get the one percent of the
junk and we
improve
about half of that one percent right the
job here
may be getting harder because pieces are
harder to read because if the computer
is so good and can't read it it's a lot
more likely it's not a good piece of
mail to begin with the address was
destroyed somehow or
uh the customer had bad information for
the address so
they've put foot lauderdale as an
abbreviation so i would put ft no matter
what not iphone correct i don't auto
correct that do it how the customer did
it okay we're not sleuths we're not
picking out details you key by the rules
you type in the address information from
what you can clearly see now the street
address works similarly where you'll do
all the numbers yep and then three plus
one ignore the direction word and key
the street name if the direction word is
the only word key it
three plus one rule so
go
all right ah but i look down to find
where the numbers are
720 where's
no uh yeah that's west boulevard so you
include that and you hit street yes 400
little way street we have internet
service from three different providers
we have three fiber optic lines coming
into the building at different points so
if any one point gets chopped off we can
maintain service because we're the only
wreck connected to every plant in the
country over 300 processing plants
including guam and anchorage alaska and
juno alaska and san juan puerto rico
it's asking for numeric and it's in c
coding so it wants the zip code it wants
a zip code 35804 go so if both the
machine can't read it and a keyer isn't
able to decipher it here
the machine at the plant sends it to the
reject bin and then somebody will
manually handle it and then if they
can't figure it out it would either get
returned to the sender and if there's no
return to sender information then it
will go to the mail recovery center okay
final test here we go uh numeric we
don't have a we don't have a numeric so
we hit none
correct then it's
outward which is
m ok space h i c s
2 5 4 5
h e a
d
street
nice okay
i mean what speed would i have to go
here 7150 keystrokes per hour it's the
speed with which you have to read that
pars it it's
much tougher than i thought it was going
to be to keep everything in your head
and this this is easy handwriting like
nothing here has been blurred and you
haven't even gotten to the ones that are
upside down or backwards or have four or
packages that have four sides to them
right and it would be an average of four
seconds for each one to keep up the pace
on average it's about four seconds that
somebody's got one of these on their
screen wow
and you did an incredible job for just
learning these rules right now i'm
impressed all right thank you i'll i'll
take that that's um
thank you so much
you